salut c'est monsieur re est arrivé il ya
quelques jours dans sa jolie boîte noire
le asus zen phone 5z un smartphone
compte en ouvrir ou à faire un run
boxing dans cette vidéo là pour regarder
un petit peu comment est faite la boîte
comment ils essaient première prise en
main est ensuite dans une prochaine
vidéo qui variable ici quelques jours un
test complet du projet en faire le tour
1 en long en large et en travers en
diagonale
on va regarder sous tous les angles on
va tester l'audio la photo la vidéo
l'écran on va tout voir on va faire le
tour complet
en attendant tout fils on la regarde un
petit peu comment et les pis j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir un petit mot sympathique
de camille immersive au coq et mis un
beau coup voir des petits mots
sympathiques donc je voulais toujours
bonjour oreiller comme prévu voici les
iphone 5 z signé asus
j'espère qu'il vous plaira il me plaît
on peut se tutoyer un canif un mois se
pose aucun problème à disposition si
besoin merci beaucoup camille donc on va
faire un tour on va regarder en bas le
boxer et voir si les poules
voici donc la boîte du zen fun 5z plutôt
bien réussi assez joli la couleur et
assez élégante
je trouve par contre effectivement elle
est assez massive quand on l'apprend de
ce point de vue là on retrouve à l'avant
quelque chose d'hyper sobre zanfan 5z
vous avez en haut et en bas
hop parce qu'on voit bien le logo asus
qui est de ce côté là sur le côté vous
avez un we love photo d'un côté comme de
l'autre et puis à l'arrière vous avez
votre numéro syrie ainsi tu si quelques
informations très intéressantes première
chose à faire c'est ouvrir à la boîte on
va enlever ce petit blister et on va
regarder
fap comment ces tissus à l'intérieur
boîte vraiment premium c'est vraiment
bien fait de la part de l'asus donc du
point de vue là c'est vraiment une bonne
réussite la matière est très agréable au
toucher à l'intérieur alors ça ça qu'on
reconnaît vraiment les marques qui font
des smartphones d'excellentes bonnes
qualités c'est lorsque vous l'ouvrez
vous avoir toujours dans l'effet waouh
est en effet découverte là vous l'avez
we love photo vous retrouvez une fois de
plus les infos que vous avez ici sur le
côté de la boîte
donc c'est vrai que c'est bien réussi
votre petite languette qui vous lie
d'ici pour venir l'ouvrir donc on va
enlever cette partie là et là qu'est ce
qu'on découvre la bête
là on a effectivement le smartphone on
voit la petite languette pour le tirer
et le faire venir c'est une invitation
une première couche up ses preuves sur
les feuillages première couche ici
deuxième couche ici maintenant hope
powell prendre voilà je vous présente
mesdames mesdemoiselles et messieurs les
usines phone 5z dans son étui de lumière
voilà tout simplement pour l'instant
alors d'ici quelques secondes on va le
déshabillent on va les filles et on va
continuer ce joli effeuillage mais pour
l'instant on le voit un peu plus en
détail ce qu'à l'intérieur de la boîte
je suis curieux de voir ce qui est si
vous avez une fois de plus une petite
languette voilà une sorte de troisième
langue et on va continuer cet assistant
un effeuillage latéral up jours et je
découvre à l'intérieur
ici j'ai mis un petit casque fort
sympathique je retrouve des petits en
bout pour le casque c'est donc là une
connectique usb et usb type c'est de ce
côté là ici j'ai mon bloc d'alimentation
allons voir maintenant ici de ce côté-là
voir ce qu'on va voir à l'intérieur on
retrouve la petite partie pour insérer
ou retirer votre petit buzz comme je la
carte sim est à l'intérieur
ah voilà ça c'est plutôt bien
vous avez une petite protection de
smartphones une petite coque
généralement les coqs qui sont fournis
avec sont pas les plus jolies jolies on
va pas se mentir mais néanmoins ça a
vraiment le mérite d'exister et ça je
trouve que ça reste quand même un très
bon point d'autant plus que rare pain
mais le tir de plus en plus mais rares
sont quand même les constructeurs qui
les fournissent avec leur smartphone
donc c'est plutôt bien
toussaint pas transparent on va pas
chercher midi à quatorze heure là dessus
et on va retrouver ici toute la petite
notice et 6h of incredible on va donc
retrouver ici quelques petites
informations sur le smartphone sur les
caméras sur l'emplacement des boutons à
quoi ils servent
un petit manuel d'utilisation de
démarrage pour le modèle que j'ai c'est
uniquement en anglais il va donc falloir
bosser un petit peu la langue de
shakespeare
ça vous fera le plus grand bien une fois
de plus je peux vraiment que donner mon
sentiment positif et très qualitatif sur
le carton d'être un carton recyclés ou
recyclables
ça fait vraiment très très qualitatif
donc ça c'est top nous voilà ensuite
arriver à l'instant fatidique on
attendait tous c'est les feuillages de
notre jolie zanfan 5z alors on va
pouvoir le faire glisser directement là
tout simplement vient par là je vous
présente le zune phone 5z j'adore le dos
ça c'est vraiment une vraie signature
chez asus cet aspect vraiment très
brillant du dos alors forcément c'est un
attrape traces de doigts ça c'est une
certitude
quoique encore par rapport à ce que j'ai
pu voir ailleurs je trouve que c'est pas
déconner non franchement
ouais c'est vrai que c'est pas du tout
déconnant je pu tester sur certains
smartphones notamment de honor vous
posez votre doigt vous avez très
clairement votre empreinte digitale là
bon là ali également mais par contre
effectivement ce n'est pas flagrant
ça se voit pas donc c'est vraiment bien
près cahier alors j'aime beaucoup cet
aspect là je trouve qu'on a vraiment un
produit d'un point de vue en tout cas
comment ces types comme ça extrêmement
premium c'est un produit qui fasse
forcément vous rappelez l'iphone 10 avec
le module photo de ce côté là néanmoins
vous avez un petit capteur d'empreintes
digitales
on a vraiment un effet que la lumière
qui vient jouer et qui donne quelque
chose de vraiment très sympa autour du
capteur d'empreintes digitales
c'est vraiment hyper hyper hyper jolis
seins espèce de rayonnement lumineux
c'est vraiment super beau on trouve
assez facilement la position de son
doigt pour venir le déverrouiller c'est
très naturel il traite plus que j'aime
sur les smartphones qui ont ce capteur
sur le côté si vous n'avez pas flirter
avec le capteur photo donc on n'allait
pas laisser de traces de doigts ça c'est
un point très positif en termes de prise
en main je trouve bien
vous allez si votre seul sur le côté
pour insérer votre carte sim et une
carte micro sd ou alors une deuxième
carte sim comme vous le souhaitez sur le
haut rien de particulier sur le côté
bouton volume ici et bouton on off
en bas un haut parleur de l'usb type c
est une prise jack voilà je trouve que
d'un point de vue esthétique comme ça ce
smartphone est vraiment super jolie
quelques infos maintenant à une mesure
153 par 75,65 soyons très précis et une
épaisseur de 7,85 mm pour un poids de
165 grammes
on va allumer la bête petite vibration
asus zen phone pendant qu'il démarre on
va tester la coque voile des lycées dans
son écrin de lumière il trouve très très
facilement sa place je suis pas sûr que
ce soit la coque la plus solide et la
plus résistante du monde pour une fois
je n'ai pas avoir un avis très négatif
parce que je crois que généralement les
corps qui sont fournies directement par
les constructeurs sont globalement pas
terry terrible celle là et pas mal elle
permet de garder effectivement le dos
très esthétique du dos on va bouger on
va retrouver toujours un petit peu 7,7
effets de lumière pour une fois
franchement c'est une bonne réussite et
c'est vraiment bien qu'asus les fourni
avec
alors qu'avant nous maintenant
configurer la reconnaissance faciale
allons-y enregistrer votre visage
c'est très rapide pour configurer son
visage pour l'enregistrer ensuite on
arrive là et là qu'est ce qu'on voit un
smartphone plutôt bien réussi parce que
je trouve vraiment intéressant et les
smartphones d'asus et combat qu'ils
utilisent des bases solides de leur
génération précédente des modèles
d'avant pour vous proposer des
smartphones vraiment évolué donc là on a
le 5 z
que ce soit en général sur les iphone 5
5 z ou 5 light ce sont des évolutions
des gammes précédentes ya peu de grands
changements en cours mais vraiment ça
avance step by step à part pas ça à
faire plutôt à la française et donc ça
c'est vraiment un poids très très très
positif
voilà donc les iphone 5 z poser
directement ici alors je trouve qu'il
est plutôt joli quand on le regarde
comme ça on voit qu'on est quasiment sur
un bord à bord on voit effectivement sur
le côté
le petit rappel que vous avez ici avec
le côté chromé qui ressort vraiment
lorsque vous le poser à plat vous avez
vraiment tout le contour chromé ça va
continuer a confirmé un côté très
esthétique est ce que c'est vraiment un
produit qui est extrêmement bien réussi
de ce point de vue là qui a vraiment un
aspect global esthétique très joli le
seul petit reproche que je pourrais leur
faire du point de vue de la face avant
c'est que vous avez ici une petite barre
voilà une petite barbe noire on n'arrive
pas directement allé chez le porc ici
c'est à dire tout simplement d'un point
de vue technologique
pour insérer un écran jusqu'en bas il
faudrait une techno qui vous permettent
je pense de plier les connectiques qui
coûterait probablement plus cher à
fabriquer que un système comme celui là
on le compare effectivement à l'iphone
10,1 par rapport à son encoches par
rapport à pas mal de choses notamment
l'emplacement de la caméra arrière mais
on n'est pas exactement comme sur
l'iphone 10 avec un écran qui arrive
tout en bas néanmoins c'est un
smartphone que quand même beaucoup moins
cher donc ça on peut pas lui en vouloir
cette encoches nous fait vraiment
vraiment vraiment penser à l'encoche
présente sur l'iphone 10 d'apple s'est
sensiblement les mêmes proportions alors
par contre là dessus y a pas de faille
saïdi vous n'allez pas de mapping en
trois dimensions de votre visage vous
avez néanmoins un déverrouillage sait
que la reconnaissance de votre visage
c'est difficile look pas du fait s'est
dit peu importe
drake s'est pas vraiment grave l'encoche
moi me dérange absolument pas je sais
qu'à peine personne qui est passé en
cochet qui râlent moi ça me pose
absolument aucun problème
voilà pour ce jeune boxing de la suze
iphone 5 z
on se retrouve d'ici quelques jours pour
la suite pour le test complet on va tous
regardés on va vraiment faire un tour
global on va regarder l'écran on va
regarder un peu comment il tourne autant
plus que celui là le 5 z je voulais pas
dit mais je détaillerai les
spécifications techniques dans la
prochaine vidéo c'est le produit le plus
haut de gamme avec un qualcomm
snapdragon 845 si giga de ram ou une
giga de ram au choix donc c'est vraiment
un smartphone qui est beaucoup plus
puissant beaucoup plus performant que le
zune phone 5 light bien évidemment et
aussi que les iphone 5
donc ça on va le regarder très
prochainement donc rester connecté
abonnez vous ratant dites moi ce que
vous en pensez
comment est ce que vous trouvez ce que
vous l'avez déjà testé ce smartphone
puisque vous avez déjà eu entre vos
mains
est ce qu'il pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que vous l'avez déjà acheté vous
marquez tout ça et puis on en parle dit
moss est ce que vous pensez des premiers
zus en règle générale est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu des iphone comment est ce
que vous les trouvez est ce que vous les
préférez par rapport à d'autres produits
concurrents est ce que vous pensez qu'un
juge globalement fabrique de bon
smartphone vous marquez tout sans
rationalité
d'ici là comme d'habitude vous laisser
jolly pour vous abonner parce que vous
allez voir car plein de choses super
cool super intéressante car et on va
parler de nouvelles marques on va parler
des smartphones on va parler de tech en
général et pas un produit différent mais
punit ces quelques temps mené avec moi
dans mes bagages on va les voyages et on
va avoir des endroits coule presque
exotique mais bon je n'en dis pas plus à
très bientôt vous embrasse
son